[Music]
man rod Simha did it
rod symbian the regulator's I got a lot
of people on Twitter hit me up a lot of
people on Instagram saying man that was
awesome I need you to tell Rob I need
you to hit out rod let him know that
what he's working with in the regulars
and what they've done is so good great
show on store for you today Bart Scott
is gonna be in studio we're going
through a bunch of the news of the day
and I let him pick where we start and
where we go it's a lot of fun and then
also I dove into some of his awful
Instagram game and whether or not he
ever wants to punch another radio host
in the face because I know that if I was
him I would be too if you were watching
on YouTube you probably saw me just
looking at my phone Antonio Brown is
live and it's this new addiction that I
had that whenever he's live I I keep
watching it's it's crazy and I don't
know what's going on and and I don't
know if you guys saw this there's this
company cameo where they offer like
personalized messages from athletes and
there's this one about a Antonio Brown
going around you could pay 500 dollars
for Antonio Brown to send a video to you
and here's the one that he was trying to
read but man I don't know if this one
was worth $500
and I heard it's a second anniversary
wedding I have you been working really
hard as a defense attorney and your
birthday is here happy birthday we
celebrate you today and while he's doing
it there's an inflatable slide behind
him in a pool but that line where he
goes wedding it's your second
anniversary wedding okay so two things
about this this company cameo and I know
one of the guys that's involved listens
to this podcast because he is currently
in my DMS asking if I would like to do a
cameo aka you could book the lef koe man
to record personal messages I don't know
how for a cost I don't know how I feel
about this because everybody knows I'm
all up in my DMS talking to you guys
anyway but I have two ideas one I'm
tempted to join cameo and instead of
$500 charge three dollars and 33 cents
to honor the 33 percent that are out
there so if you want me to to hate on
your friends I haven't decided if I'm
doing this yet
I'm really putting this out to you guys
to tell me should I do this
the other idea that I have is I went on
to cameos website it is incredible the
NFL players that you could book if you
wanted to get them to record a message
now the expensive ones there are three
guys that are charging $1000 Josh Norman
Pierre Garcon and kam chancellor they're
clearly in it for the money next up
Urlacher's 540 I would assume an honor
254 you'd get brett farr for 500 but the
value you scroll down on this and it's
like look at this I could get a $25
video message from Jake but Landon
Collins is pre-placed priced at $25 then
you go all the way to the bottom and for
$1 I can get a guy named Eric McCoy I
can get Kyle Pico for $2 the do
from the Denver Broncos I mean these are
some fattiest Lewis for $5.00 so what
I'm asking the the left go faithful the
homies right now is go on to this cameo
website I'm not working with them
okay I'm not yet I'm not this is no
business deal I'm not making anything
off them right now I promise I'm just
thinking rich NFL players should we have
record an intro that's like yo it up
it's fad Louis I like to throw balls and
sometimes people go whoa big offseason
like which NFL players should we get
like who should do the thing for left co
PR that's like I make a lot of dumb
decisions but when I need smart
decisions I use left go PR I mean we get
sua Cravens for $10 then I can get DJ
swear injure 4/5 I could get DJ swear
injure to say I hate when coaches don't
pull their weight but I love the left
coast show like we could do this so I'm
curious what who are the most random NFL
players that we can get who are the ones
that are funny and you know is there
ever a reason to pay $500 for Brett
Favre you know what what could we get
Brett Favre to say that will be kind of
funny I'm just trying to find a way to
get some funny stuff out of this for the
homies and this show that's where my
brain is right now also Thursday night
this podcast comes out Thursday morning
my NBA grind continues check out the NBA
Twitter show I'm gonna be on there with
Kenyon Martin Carlos Boozer and Omar the
face and name of house of highlights so
I'm gonna be doing that check me out
Thursday night and also I'm gonna be
doing something I think with that pro
football chase my man Isaac we might be
doing some Instagram lives in the near
future all right I just wanted to give
you guys some information on that and
this nugget that Monday it's looking
like we're gonna have the official new
name of this show and I'm telling you
that there are some changes coming some
real Lefko changes but enough about that
now it's time for
conversation with Bart Scott I hope you
are ready for some [ __ ] honesty
and I'm coming with a curse right away
because we have Bart Scott now on people
a real goes wrong always now I have a
contract I'm gonna read the contract to
you this is how we get down now for the
left Co it's a 33 percent guest contract
we've seen this last week
it reads Bart I Bart Scott hereby agree
to give my full 100% to fulfill the 33
percent needed to make the show great
just so you know I give 33 Vega 33 you
give 33 I will focus on not givin 110
because that would throw off the math
also if I feel like I wanna curse I'm
going to curse and I'm not gonna hold it
back like some snitch gosh do you agree
let's do it I agree and I understand
about standing and playing my position
thanks I'm not gonna try be Beyonce I'm
gonna stand it back and be my shell and
just blend in no I want beyond 33% okay
that's true over there Michelle there
Michelle you're Beyonce what's the other
one
I'm Kelly Kelly Rowland definitely be
Kelly yeah Michelle is like
like she's replaceable yes a hundred
percent and well she has been replaced
the right chief was a fill-in damn
so I'm Kelly Rowland you don't say but I
will say this I did have a crush on
Michelle for a little bit did you I did
too skinny for my yeah all right Kelly
Kelly showed me something when she had
her Nelly have went out on our own she
did the songs with like with Nelly
yeah Nelly it was big I didn't I didn't
realize you know that that chocolate
mocha was kind of nice hey it was
getting it was getting overshadowed by
the Sun that we saw my engagement photos
but I I'm okay so here's what we're
gonna do I have six stories that people
are talking about but I don't want to do
this normal I want you to pick but
here's how it works they're all hot
takes from me that I'll start off and
then if you want to confirm it or deny
it we can do that so one two three four
five and six Nick get that drum roll
ready hit it
and Bart's got the first left go hot
take you will pick is
number four I gonna read it out loud
Irina's yes and Tonio Brown would be
arena by Friday Antonio Brown I am
reading all the tea leaves and Adam
Schefter has come out and he said that
makes it official then he said by Friday
he will be on a new team and Antonio
Brown the shefter says new place by
Friday Derek Carr came out today and
said I hope he's in play it would be
great to add a guy like that to your
team talent like that
I'm just curious like you know [ __ ]
about Antonio first of all as Derek Carr
go build a team well he said come on peg
Antonio Brown and I could totally see
Derek Carr on like the rest of the
dolphins the dolphins or the Jaguars why
he's sitting there worried about where
Antonio Brown is coming you need to
worry about them keeping him on the team
with three first-round draft picks they
may go Kyle or Murray do you agree with
me though I think that the Raiders have
three first-round picks Jon Gruden loves
veterans and I think that he's gonna go
I love that fire I want that fire on my
team he loves veterans a little too much
they were oldest roster and football
last year they need to have a youth
movement he needs to you know address he
did that last year with Jordy Nelson
Jordy Nelson's old yes like why Branca
Antonio Brown there I understand you got
to get some splash to try and take the
Vegas to sell tickets yeah because
you're not the only show in town but I
believe the most natural fit for Antonio
Brown is the Green Bay Packers right
because their team that's ready to win
right now sure they have a new coach
they have a new philosophy now they're
supposedly are gonna start spending on
free agency
Aaron Aaron was Aaron Rodgers or Aaron
Jones right Aaron Jones is good they
have a solid line Jimmy Graham still
there I don't know why talk about
stealing
bro talk about still these guys been
stealing without a mask on he's one of
those guys that was like making Pro
Bowls because of his name for half this
exactly like he went out there to the
Pacific Northwest and we forgot totally
about him it just shows you that you
know it was more about Drew Brees and
not more about him you saw that Ben
Watson had a resurgence got another
contract so I mean they should be in the
market for maybe Jared Cook
all right well I want the true Bart
Scott though like with what's going on
in Pittsburgh yeah I I went onto your
Instagram yeah and I saw a little bit
down there's a picture of you sacking
Ben Roethlisberger No and you're talking
a little [ __ ] to Steelers fans yeah
what do you see because I feel like you
know this situation what's really going
on well we all know you know what the
comments were of the general manager
saying that you know it's 53 children
you know you can't talk to a grown man
like that and you can't talk to a black
athlete like that saying that you know
some some he's a he's the adult in the
room bunch of kids especially when
Antonio Brown is potentially a Hall of
Fame player fuels if you're gonna rank
him right now maybe on bail and the rest
of the running backs in the league
they'll still be like you know top three
yeah
Antonio Brown one two or three yep Ben
Roethlisberger's farther down on that
list yes
so I deserve the same respect if not
more than he did he deserves this is not
saying this to the bud Dupree or saying
this to some backup you say this to your
Hall of Fame player that has performed
and Ben has thrown his teammates under
the bus consistently and he's a guy that
always points the finger never the thumb
and we neither gonna get about you know
some of the allegations that he's had
we're talking about a guy a quarterback
that was suspended for six games because
of conduct detrimental you're not gonna
talk about the I guess we can talk about
what the allegations were that he
pressed up on it on a female insider in
Georgia inside of a bathroom right wise
people guarded the door yeah things of
that sort so you're telling me as a
player Antonio Brown that this guy's the
leader he's still adult then that's
disrespectful to me and then for my for
that same quarterback to say hey he
needs to run a better route with all the
interceptions that he's thrown with all
the mistakes that he's made the first
Pro Bowl that means first who bought 81
you know he was more of a passenger than
he was the driver of the car sure now
he's a great player but it's different
ways to lead and you've never heard a
great quarterback in this league throw
anybody under the bus maybe Tom Brady
once or twice when the
offensive line you did perform up to par
he got hit Aaron did it for like the
first time in this offseason when he
said the young receivers need to step it
up and everybody was like yeah you've
never heard Rodgers do this before young
receivers he said Antonio should I read
a better route yeah meanwhile he threw
it to a defensive lineman what what are
we talking about my other question
though is being on the field with these
guys yeah could you ever notice weird
friction on that team I never never any
friction between between those two but
then there's pretty early on I think
what happens is you're able to be more
of yourself the more successful you are
sometimes you understand it's not your
place you just got to shut up yeah you
know so he couldn't say anything when I
was still in the league because he was
young and he was becoming Antonio
breaking over for like a manual Sanders
right well he was replacing Hines Ward
yeah you know in the manual Sanders had
just left and he became a number one
receiver I think that you know ban has
to take account of building we're gonna
see how good being is now because be
careful what you wish for
because now was three B's now to of ran
out you've read a lot of town we're
gonna see how good you are and all of a
sudden Ben is you know re-energized now
he won't say now he wants an extension
but he'd been threatening retirement for
the last two years which one is it Ben I
think the scariest thing is I was saying
during the year that I think juju is
better than Antonio Brown just because I
think there's certain things juju can do
that a B can't do at this point but I
saw this stat and actually opened my
eyes Antonio Brown was doubled on eight
and a half percent of snaps last year
juju was doubled on point eight percent
so we're gonna see a whole new type of
juju what he's gonna face without a be
my last question would be are you are
you at all worried about a B just just
with kind of what we're seeing like I do
i demolition man with the with the blind
must be like crying out to us I want
everyone to be their own individual and
to have their own swag and be different
but is there any part of you that's like
man I hope baby's okay I hope he's okay
cuz you know look like I thought maybe
you know sometimes you see guys walking
around town especially in Hollywood and
they're looking kind of weird if fat
they got a beard yeah they're looking
old you know but usually they're
preparing for a movie role
so when I see like the blond mustache
I'm like okay make my dogs in ready and
listen nowadays everything's being it's
being rebooted right yeah coming to
America
it's supposed to be a part - yeah right
all these shows Boy Meets World
everything's coming back maybe
demolition man he's playing a role of
Wesley Snipes you don't entrepreneur but
you don't want to put it in a hint
so the remix put it in this - Jim well
done a B all right let me get the
drumroll Nick it is time for the second
number for Bart Scott one two three five
or six let's go with number two number
two okay I'm gonna stay with the evens
Oh Tyreke Hill is the best wide receiver
in the NFL I say this because the Chiefs
are negotiating a record-setting deal
for Tyree kill and I'm watching the
shows on television and they're going
he's not the best he's the scariest but
he's not the best and I'm sitting there
going if there's one wide receiver that
every team goes we need a double cover
him and the safety needs to drop back
why can't he be the best I know that he
maybe doesn't have the size of a Julio
or the technique of an Antonio Brown but
if he's the only guy in the NFL that can
take it for 80 yards out why can't he be
the best when I say he's the most
dangerous because of what he can do in
the special team game as well sure and
the fact that you can hand him the ball
as a receiver the best in the most
versatile is totally different you know
he's the most well-rounded dangerous
okay my most dangerous I think he's the
best he's the most explosive right so
you know at times you can say Randy Moss
was the best and the most explosive
because you get him you can get in you
know weird cuz Randy was a taller
receiver right he still can hit him with
the reverses you can take shots with him
down the field now he wasn't a threat on
special teams but Odell Beckham is like
that as well he's explosive he you can
do these type of types of things he can
take a slant just as well as been a
vertical receiver
Tyreke I believe is learning to run more
of the route tree he understood
everybody's gonna play off so he's
learning he was but it's just
sustainable right there's the question
right so you give him all this money in
his weird because
you look at the Kansas City cheese and
where they're at you know they were a
couple of good defensive players from
being able to you know really make a
real Super Bowl run but if you're gonna
pay Tyree kill this record-setting type
of contract then that means you're gonna
lose d4 because they're saying okay you
have a second-round draft pick what they
tendered him with the second-round level
or a franchise I mean you can you know
he's available for you if you give up a
second-round draft pick Justin Houston
is holding them hostage they know
nobody's gonna trade so they're gonna
cut them yeah so then yeah you pay Tyree
kill but how you gonna address this
defense for your new pretty new defense
coordinator when it was a 31st
defensively I think I think getting rid
of Houston may open them up to sign some
of these safeties that are on the market
some corner backs they panned their
safety is the highest pace a bit again
well yes but I mean their safety along
side you can't invest that much money I
get it but I think when you look at the
D line they invested a lot of draft
picks last year into some D lineman yep
I think Chris Jones is top five
defensive lineman maybe and I think so
and you think respect NOLA day they're
gonna use them more like Justin Tuck
which is but then your OC you mean
you're supposed to be d4 but you get rid
of him for a second-round draft pick
completely just using is yours Michael
Strahan you know you're almost broke his
record he's your solid stop the run yeah
still get to the quarterback dad to what
you said though about sustainability
because the Chiefs defense is a whole
nother issue but in terms of Tyreke I
think they have the quarterback that
makes Tyreke the most sustainable to
have to give Patrick mahomes the fastest
wide receiver in the NFL it's open
underneath for 16 games a year it's the
perfect combination do we expect
packaging mahomes
to perform at an MVP level again next
year yeah I see this see this a
difference fucking's
see but that's a difference like now
it's out there right now it's out there
I don't know now it's out there they're
gonna find what he can't do and they're
gonna make him now he's gonna have to
win with a counterpunch now he's gonna
have to perform with this B game because
they're gonna take away what he does
best
and they're gonna weather weather is
getting them out of the pocket making a
roll to his left it's good they're gonna
do something it's gonna be some film
that some great defensive coordinators
are gonna see they're gonna break it
down and they're gonna make them beat
them a different way I think do you are
you afraid of semi walk-ins
that's the contract selling Walker
that's why that contract is definitely
killing them but if if Sammy Watkins is
my number three behind Tyreke Kelsi in
them that's a tough matchup for
defensive easy two three yeah but him
being your number three is stopping you
from sign ID for that contract he Sammy
Watkins for 16 min somebody need to be
fired just from that that was what well
they a receiver Percy was fired I don't
I think he was the the GM then but I I
look at the the Chiefs and I go the
toughest games that Patrick mahomes had
last year first game in New England
where they just showed blitzing and then
dropped everybody out he came back and
hung up 40 plus the Rams game he played
bad and he put up like six touchdowns in
500 yards I am willing to make a bet
with you I don't know if he goes 5050
touchdowns but I think mahomes I don't
think you'd bet against my home's I'm
not gonna bet against him but I'm
telling you he's gonna drop the
production's gonna drop you think you
can see you can shave off a lot listen
and you'd never know if Kelsey's gonna
be healthy in the entire year he's one
of these guys he just got his ankle
cleaned out I always jump in if you
don't got any shakin bacon you jumping
is not the I play with Todd Heap yeah he
had the strongest and he had to had a
strongest nick in the history of
football because he landed on about ten
times a season just just go down man
like do something I know well yeah well
like the number one tight end that jumps
the most right now is my kiseki of the
Dolphins every time I turned it on he's
jumping and I'm like I don't know if
you're doing this because you're scared
and you just don't wanna get hit square
that's like the cool jumps that's like
the cool thing like let me jump and make
a myth and and get two yards is it
really worth two yards for you to get
Don Beebe you know why because then
you're gonna be on [ __ ] Instagram okay
there you go all right
drum roll let me get it back 1 3 5 & 6
let's go with old number
that's a good one yeah Charlie Cassady
must be stopped thanks to what the hell
first of all let's talk about Charlie
casting you'll agree with my heart yes
Charlie somebody's horse stop charlie
I don't know if he's like an early onset
dementia what he's going on but he's not
the same person he's not the sharpest
tool in the shed anymore and I know he's
riding off of that off his reputation
first of all first of all the Jets hired
him to do a an objective search yes he
hired his friend of course inside game
yeah inside mu I'm not gonna lie so the
reason I brought this up Charlie Castle
he's the one that made the comments that
he asked around NFL games Collyer Kyler
Murray was the worst he's ever heard in
terms of interacting with team's
leadership study habits board work not
good not good not good
let me tell you I'm watching the combine
this weekend and as I'm watching it I'm
looking at the bottom line and I see
Daniel Jeremiah's mock draft and it goes
one through 32 and that lasts a few
minutes then it says Bucky Brooks mock
draft and it goes for a few minutes and
then it said Charlie Casserly Smok draft
and I literally said out loud as I'm
eating you know it's a nice gesture that
they're even letting him still do that
like that's what I thought in my head
like who's genuinely reading carlie
charlie casually smock draft I have
thought for years that the main reason
he's been there is that he's been at the
network for a long time so they keep it
out of respect you keep them all so
somebody has to do the hits on NFL
Network at 12:30 on a Tuesday and I
thought that's why he was there to take
his reports and to create this firestorm
that Lincoln Reilly has to come out and
go no I've actually talked to NFL
coaches right and they're saying the
opposite it's time to let it go and I
know that everyone's gonna go everyone's
trying to play it safe and goes yeah I
don't know about that report other NFL
Network employees are coming out and
against it I'm just saying I'll be the
[ __ ]
I'll be the [ __ ] no more Charlie
Casserly has been fun
he drafted Mario Williams same thing
Bill Polian yeah yeah it's the same
thing if if we're gonna if we're gonna
players when they get older you got to
move on from some analysts to yeah
because they just want to get out the
house at this point in a golf course
like that's what that is that's what
that's all about
listen at some point it becomes a point
where all our grandparents get to that
point where they don't give a [ __ ] about
what they say yeah and I think he's to
that point and he's just showing up
because he wants to be around people
think hey these are my friends yeah
that's like going to the gym you see the
old dude in area two gym he's never
really doing nothing
yes every time you trying to do
something he stops you want to talk
about the games don't worry about your
own yeah yeah he's looking for comfort
so the other thing I'll say is Lincoln
Riley said a few weeks ago something
that everyone kind of laughed at he said
Kyler Murray maybe is the best runner
since Barry Sanders ok this didn't see
now he dropped but the only thing I'm
gonna say about that is the last time a
young coach in college overhyped his
quarterback and we laughed at him
it was Dabo Sweeney saying if you pass
on deshaun Watson it's like passing on
Michael Jordan and we all said you're
supposed to say there coach so I have a
little RIA in my head I'm like oh man
but baby Lincoln Reilly's right but the
shot Watson's more Ron Harper than he is
Jordan like like he he's good personal
he needs to wreck it recognize and get
on the scale and realize that he ain't
no wolf like he sit up there listen the
shot washing needs to figure out that
when he sees a 52 or 57
maybe a 45 he might want to just slide
now you look up the little dudes like
stay in your weight class we got weight
classes for a reason I do think he's
good I get concerned sometimes with his
knee and the fact that they really
haven't addressed the offensive line but
yeah you know calimary best running you
know that's overhyped seeds where do you
stand on Kyler right now I think I'm
expecting you ever like watched a ton of
film but I'm just curious what you no no
no no listen I think listen what I like
is the fact that listen he's always been
510 so people who said oh he's short he
can't throw from the pocket the same you
know his teammates are the guys he
played with the guys he played against
may not be as good as the players in NFL
but there's tallest they all right and
the fact that he threw you know ninety
percent from the pocket and its accuracy
and the fact that we just saw
you know Baker Mayfield come out of this
change system and it translated to the
league immediately and his team improved
with him at quarterback after Baker
right like it fell off and it's because
he adds a different element rushing for
over a thousand yards you know I think
it's all about fit it takes somebody and
his agent came out and said it even
before we were talking about was talking
about Dave get him in a day and what
he's doing in fact that he's a dinosaur
and the fact that he doesn't see that
the game has changed in evolution you
know some of these guys still have that
Ernie Accorsi type of [ __ ] did they have
where they look for a certain person has
to be a certain height certain weight
search speed yeah yeah greatly
Singletary told me a long time to
greatness comes in every shape and size
right so I think kylie marie can
potentially be that and i think the fact
that you know he's put in the work he
decided to hey i'm gonna you know play
football I'm not gonna attempt to play
baseball I'm going to commit a hundred
percent you have to look where the
league is going and what he's able to do
the fact that he's a mobile quarterback
and he still can throw from the pocket
means that you don't have the same thing
happened to him that happened to Lamar
Jackson right let's everybody figure out
that you you know design runs and then
they put more athletes out there and
then that's my party morning wig theory
is that Marty morning will give you six
regular-season games where he looks like
a genius Jesse yeah and then when like
you play another playoff team again
they're like nah bro that's why I'm in
Baltimore do the one of the hubs the
Southwest a game a ticket real quick got
him out of town saying great room come
show us I have to I have to theories
about calimary I think this is the
perfect draft for him to come out and I
think it's the worst draft for him to
come out know what I think it's the
perfect draft because we just saw a
former baseball player in Patrick
mahomes and a short quarterback in Baker
Mayfield have a lot of success so it
kind of goes oh he could sling it like
mahomes with down here and up here and
then also size is an issue I think it's
the worst because other than Haskins
there isn't another quarterback for us
to just break down in the media last
year if you focused on dartle too much
then we're gonna talk about Lamar then
we're gonna talk about Baker
so no one we couldn't focus on one guy
yeah we have one guy to focus on which
means for the next two months we're just
gonna poke regular and anonymous Scouts
are gonna say and
so that wasn't showed up to his birthday
party or something you know but that's
exactly well that's what they're doing
right they're trying to break him down I
think secretly whoever leaked that or
reportedly suppose he said that to
casually he's trying to tank his value
so that people can say okay so they can
try and grab maybe Miami's trying to
grab him
maybe Washington's trying to see if he
can fall that far right and they don't
have to move up as far but I think you
know because Gettleman is a dinosaur I
believe that Cuyler Murray you see the
boom or bust right right see that it's
high stake poker right because does you
come in like Pat white and get hit with
the easy button and retire and go back
and put the baseball cap up the next day
take one of these man hits or you know
does he become successful but I think if
you can imagine him going to the Giant
and you talk about how about broken him
down have I seen him play yes I have and
with his ability to run and escape he
will always hold the backside defensive
end in the back side linebacker that's a
created more exactly holy crap he's
going on he's going 11 on nine because
he's holding two players because what
happens is if he keeps it not only do
the defensive end out to get there but
he's able to circle the defense then
that backside linebacker hazards a
pretty good combination to that is they
just go see but the thing is it's not
enough other weapons around see but so
now so now so now listen you're putting
it in the belly right so now the pass
rush is knelling boy because this guy's
flattening out because you're putting it
in the belly or he's holding up and he's
doing the old option stand square and
waiting to hold the wine back
quarterback reversed you might hold the
safety and then if you got a hotel on a
slant that's what I'm saying it's all so
now it's some people talk about Evan
Engram so a simple yeah because you
putting it in their belly your cause of
Paul's for the linebackers they're not
gonna get any depth you got Odell
running a slant behind safeties playing
deep because he's already doubling Odell
so now you got so many options it's such
a simple offense yeah it's just you know
and it could be explosive I think now
that I'm realizing to Kyler Odell say
Quan is chaos knockouts but if they do
get him training camp with Eli and Kyler
no no I mean that might be the most
biggest guy
an athletics whatever no no no if you do
that if that's where you going you tell
you tell Eli thank you but no thank you
you get you can't have that distraction
because we're all gonna want to see we
are gonna see Carl Appetit
they're obsessed with Eli they're
obsessed I think our key guy
picket pictures on it on the terrace and
everybody everybody's afraid that he got
he got he got a minute I getting 23 they
let Landon Collins go
I mean we're gonna talk about gentlemen
in a sec yeah cuz I know one of these is
like okay all right so drum roll three
five and six
[Music]
don't wait put your dip oh I don't know
whichever one I don't care they're all
good
FIBA they're all fire takes CSI
Cleveland CSI Cleveland I have three
pictures here for you sir you're a my
investigator let's do it three different
Cleveland Browns tweeted something out
yesterday that's make giving me pause
we're gonna start off first with
damarious Randall read that tweet what
do you see there John Dorsey low-key a
genius
so damarious Randall tweeted out John
Dorsey lochia genius I have this now
Jarvis Landry what did Jarvis Landry
tweet make sure your mind right and come
to Cleveland who are we talking to I
don't know
ghost then this one from David and Joe
ku love this [ __ ] love this conduit he's
African reckon I doing exactly if you'd
like to look this [ __ ] Brenda perfect
that was good
so it made me think what the hell's
happening right now Jamie Collins was
just released the Cleveland Browns now
have the third most money for free
agency I have some names I'm gonna read
them to you and I and I want to hear at
the end here the names there's maybe
Odell Antonio Brown Le'Veon Bell soo CJ
Mosely Anthony bar Landon Collins Earl
Thomas honey badger and maybe they're
getting really excited for Mitch Morse
maybe a little muffins were there any
names that it would explain CSI
Cleveland with these tweets
give me uh CJ Mosley okay cuz it's taken
that's what I thought too you're taking
from an individual rival and you're in
you're rubbing it in his face you have
to be motivated because you wouldn't pay
me so I went to Cleveland and it's been
Ravens that have left there's some all
Lewis
Gary Baxter that have left and played
with in the division they have a lot of
money if you had I don't know if CJ
Mosley's are listening all of this I
feel like it might be CJ Mosley and soda
I CJ and a B take them from the Steelers
look at this you left me for this but
then does that mean that the Browns have
to trade with yeah yeah that never
that'll never work that never happened
so yeah I probably have to take pause on
that but CJ Mosley you know I think if
they got CJ Mosley and Landon Collins
that might excite me I don't know about
Landon I'd rather go honey badger
because in that division what does the
Ravens have they had three great tight
ends yep
you look at McDonald you're like well
just more in the box and so is like
triple Peppers like you need a guy that
can actually yeah yeah so you need a guy
that can get off the hash as a guy that
can you know potentially match up
remember honey badger used to be a
cornerback but I think the honey badger
may be coming out here to the Giants
that's why they let Landon Collins go
because he thrived in bachelors our
defense sure I think I I'm hoping
because then they'll Odell also tweeted
out like I'm not gonna say nothing but I
thought that was more about Landon
Collins ain't nobody taking on that
money in that distraction he loves it
out here hatreds really tried to trade
for him though supposedly no no no no no
I'm gonna wink wink at you like okay no
no okay let me call it let me call Tom
Brady and see if that's the facts I'll
call Charlie Casserly all right give me
the drumroll we're down to three and six
number three all right the safety
position doesn't have a problem so I
noticed that last year one of the big
storylines was how none of the
free-agent top safeties got signed I was
one of those people that said are the
owners trying to devalue the safety
class now there's a ton of free agent
safeties Landon Collins Earl Thomas
Adrian Amos of the Bears Tyrann Mathieu
LaMarcus Joyner haha Clinton Dix Eric
Weddle just got cut yeah but I went back
and I looked at who the free agents were
last year yeah and it was it was honey
badger again Kenny Vaccaro Eric Reid
Morgan Burnett trae Boston and when I
reread him I went oh they weren't that
great but it was just the list no one
took off the time but anybody ever been
a bigger disappointment in Vacarro
he's definitely I just remember that one
Monday Night Football game where he got
sauced and Rudin was like he's awful
he's off on I was like whoa he may be a
candidate to be the next mark bear he
might add that and go to the gym become
a linebacker Perry 1522 Kristine it's a
protein shake
come on down yeah there too you can say
that but these names Landon Collins RL
Thomas Adrian emos I talked to Conor
Rogers a stick to football he says that
there's right now consensus that there's
there's about five safeties that should
be first or second-round picks in the
draft so I wasn't sure if there was a
lot of guys coming out but my feeling is
I don't think the safety positions being
devalued I think these guys will get
paid yeah and do you think those guys
Landon Collins for Mel Thomas it's about
how much are they gonna get paid because
Earl Thomas is arguably probably that
he's the best one on that list not
arguably he's the best one on that list
and he's only 29 years old and he's one
of the very few that it has scheme
versatility right so he's a guy that
could play in a box you got a little
buddy got a little Bob Sanders in him
you got a man here come up hit you take
but also he has a little Polamalu and
you where he can get off the hashes he
can play the game like he can open up to
the middle of the field or feet turn and
take over hands the ball just seems to
find him sprite because because in he he
believes what he sees yeah but all these
other guys they they are elite right see
I grew up in an era it's kind of hard to
him say this do name Darren Darren
Sharper yeah of course when he was elite
yep and when entry was their father Milo
Dawkins no Dawkins you know so it was
great safeties it's not a lot of great
safety play a lot of I believe a lot of
those guys that are great candidates to
be safeties are moved up to play
linebacker and what we're starting to
see is we're starting to see
quarterbacks convert it to safety yes
you know just saw one in Green Bay Josh
Jackson you have some good safety play
like I like Gary James I love German
James is right now Keon O'Neill yes
right so you have a couple but they're
far for you between you know Eric Berry
with one of these guys you look at these
guys too Landon's and in the box guy
Earl can kind of do everything de Adrian
had a great season the last two seasons
with the Bears and he can fly around the
tyrant is so versatile but he's had some
injury brother
LaMarcus I think he got franchise tagged
last year and he was playing good but he
got exposed in the Super Bowl and I
think it's the worst thing to have on
tape ha Clinton Dix I don't know what he
is anymore yeah because when he went to
Washington and his and I looked at like
the PFF numbers it was like
what happened Eric Weddle I wanted to
ask you about yeah because Eric Weddle I
saw some I forget who it was somebody
put it out that they talked to a bunch
of coaches and Eric Weddle was the
reason the Ravens were so hard to
prepare for
I remember the Chargers Ravens game
Philip Rivers came out and goes I mean
he could read everything so I don't
think he's just fast and he can hit as
hard but he's like that leader on the
backend the rate the Ravens have made a
career out of slow safeties that were
smart remember finding Jim leaner and
I'm not sure they brought that up every
forget and I'm not I'm not making a
competitor why they're White I'm not
doing that because also the wildlands we
were the same way yeah he didn't have a
lot of speed but what they what the
Ravens are good at you know
traditionally it's taken a guy like that
and using his smarts to put them all
over the place so what you saw is you
saw WeDo really you know looking at some
old area from he'll be up on the Box Cup
and then he'll he'll look back that's
post that's post snap
you know disguising just what the NFL
zalem and that's understanding what the
what the snap count is all about the
tendencies of the quarterback so that's
next-level scouting in do you think they
have somebody on their roster already
that they're gonna feel comfortable
putting in that role were you surprised
Eric when I got cut no because I
understand we understand what's
happening in Baltimore right
Suggs has held them hostage a little bit
because he's not the same player but
he's a legacy player he's one of these
guys and he's still productive enough
for the fan base to warn that you bring
him back at some number even though he's
made a kazillion dollars rectum and you
look at what's happening is a lot of
their young players are finally coming
up and now you have to pay him mmm so
now you got to make tough decisions fred
urban za'darius smith CJ mostly i mean
john brown and they just pay they just
paid they just paid their nickel back to
$29
tavon young right so now that's the
problem see and so now that they're
trying to that's why Flacco had was not
coming back regarding yeah because they
couldn't afford it because they couldn't
afford to retain these guys they
couldn't afford to upgrade any skill
positions on the outside right so now
you know they had to let WeDo go because
you can't let Jefferson go because he's
the younger player he has a longer shelf
life right I mean they're secondary with
Marlin Humphrey
Brandon Carr Jimmy Smith though Jimmy
Smith that's a high contract to pay for
him he's he's good at times but he has
hiccups and he's been in and off the
field
yeah who the suspensions that's the one
that's kind of crazy they gave him top
like top of the market money right and
the Ravens will do that they'll give
certain players top top market money you
like why is he still there it's an
interesting time for the Ravens Ozzie
Ozzie Newsome moving on and you have the
new GED coffee but he's been waiting for
it forever
he turned down two Jets but the reason
it's exciting is you have Lamar
Jackson's rookie contract for the next
four years right
so how can they build around him where
do they build so much of that offensive
line is young players - yeah well you
got Marshall yonder who's gonna walk
into the Hall of Fame you know and as he
found him in a third-round pick from
Iowa but you know I'm concerned about
Lamar Jackson you know because I don't
know we don't know how much growth we're
gonna say yes he's gonna need a lot of
growth because in that division they
will hit you yeah he has that rg3 type
of body you know I worry more about him
than I do about Colin Murray because
even though Kyler is only 207 by him
only being 510 that's a stocky body
that's a Rockies that's a Russell Wilson
body so it's not a lot of stuff to hit
and he's long and lean so now standing
man Cox yeah did you hear Jalen Ramsey
said oh hope he has some pulse with that
about you know getting Nick Foles and he
says he hopes that the the nickname is
true like bro well I'm curious this is
probably they're probably gonna take
this out but if you noticed that your
quarterback lived up to that nickname
would it give you more confidence in his
play
no okay got uncomfortable but because
that means you can't meet watching but
you were you were saying that Lamar
Jackson and he can get hit and if he
gets hit one time it's in trouble I mean
you saw him late in the season getting
hits and you didn't know if he was gonna
get back up you know I'm excited that
Greg Romans becoming the full OC now and
I know only from this I felt like last
year with when Gus Edwards really
started stepping up he built this great
running offense but they never put
anything on top
and I know that greg has had a lot of
success with certain mobile quarterbacks
and maybe it's overrated afrinic colin
kaepernick Tyrod Taylor had his best
years with Greg Roman and now he's going
there I mean Greg Roman is a good
coordinator I don't know if I could say
coordinator he's great with the run game
you know people don't realize you know
this is like his third stint with the
Ravens mm-hmm he was there when Jamal
ran for almost 2000 yards okay
he was to run coordinator see a cool guy
yeah he he so he was the runt
coordinator but I don't know if he
builds the passer
yeah yeah because it's just kind of put
in a billion shots right and you got to
have better concepts and you know the
Ravens are unique and I heard they said
they were gonna draft like nobody else
they're gonna do things that other
people are gonna find kind of quirky
because what they want to do is they
want to be a unicorn they want to have a
unique
harness way to they don't have a unique
office you saw the pagers do that right
right like everybody spraying everybody
out okay so II so when you see this hole
ground-and-pound in your face
you've never gonna bear to see it and
you're not ready to tackle and
linebackers don't come down here no more
here's a full take that mark Baron yeah
yeah 220 pounds take this necro exactly
means but you know we'll see if they can
develop him to throw in the pocket but
it's gonna take Lamar Jackson some
self-awareness to say you know what I
need to go to the lab and I need to work
learn how to throw from the pocket and
let that be a bonus we see what's
happening with camp it sounds big enough
and more equipped to be able to take
that beating I don't need my quarterback
having you know 10 15 scheduled like
runs that's not off script plays ya know
because you can't you can't live it I
will say one thing about Lamar as I felt
he was very good at getting out of
harm's way last year now as you said one
bad decision erases 50 good decisions
you don't see him all the time but I'm
pulling for him I am I mean come on I'm
a raven yeah I'm saying I was gonna say
you still have that blood no doubt I
still all my charities are still down
there I go down there all the time you
know me
Ravens play the Jets you're taking the
Ravens I mean I don't at this point I
don't care I prefer for good stories
yeah
yeah I don't your favorite player right
now mine's probably George Kittel George
now my him or Quinton Nelson
cuz they're my guys think McDonald's
funny man oh yeah I mean cool baby yeah
yeah I like first of all biggest face I
think if you ever did that to it to me
like I don't understand how that how you
don't show up in it like you can't
embarrass me on TV like that you can't
you can't step on me like that bro it's
supposed to be wrong for that steel yeah
so disrespectful you we got a fight
would you really
we gotta fight to win something if the
Taylor lawand Josh Norman thing happened
to you where you just lost a game and
then someone came up and was doing your
celebration right in your face what
would have transpired see you see that's
the thing right so you know I remember
when we used to playing T L used to do
it he did the Ray Lewis dance and all
that stuff
listen it's our job to not let him
celebrate if you score then that's my
bad that's cool
now any of that dirty stuff you got to
see me in some real life stuff and you
know if you want to act like have I ever
had that I try chased Richie incognito
into the locker room yeah yeah was this
this was a he's playing for the the
ramps and you know all game just going
to people late he's trying to take him
out and I told him after the game I'm
gonna kick your ass and how did he take
it when you sent it right then so he
thought I was joking so then other he's
trying to give me a plan I swung on him
and then I Danny ran and then his back
right after the game yeah yeah you swung
a suit like that yeah and then and then
and so he just started running they
grabbed his coaches grabs today I tried
to fight them because I said you coached
that [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean so you the
coach Turner allowed to happen so if he
would hurt me I deserve to kick y'all
ass too and how they out of the trees
yeah we know he's crazy doesn't listen
listen how far did your chase go is this
like Houston rocket they caught me on it
they caught me on like two ten start
like at midfield caught me on like the
ten and then like did he DM you and he
was like sorry no man know this before
that he actually told my agent I like
what's over Bart like you got the right
one you got the right would what I would
not talk [ __ ] to you has anyone like
really
had a good shit-talk moment to you that
just kind of caught you off guard like
um it was good meeow meeow Chad Johnson
you had this whole thing like where like
he like like like it's funny I got this
Holly I'm doing this like career
highlight tape thing yeah and a lot of
it's like some of it is like when I'm
playing him he's Mike and you can see
kind of like how I used to treat him and
he like what he used to say like bark
can i play football bark like and we had
this whole thing with NFL never we're
going out of me was called I called him
like the Dave Chappelle of football and
that's when he had two blond hair right
and you know I was trying to find a
Hynes work too but really Richie
incognito was the guy that you know used
to get honey
amia with the Cologne used to go out to
Italy but will you don't talk back but I
just I would talk to anybody that's my
nickname was Matt backer cuz I fought
all the time but you know I digress your
name also titty head no no don't worry
about no no titty titty head is one of
my teammates now playing for in college
gosh it's so like when we see him I we
call him titty hen I grab his head all
the time and he get Max's shapes a
certain way I think I got I I'll try and
find a picture of city a city a man I
always squeeze it like his ball here so
he gets mad you know how you got that
little friend that you just like bullion
so I like palm his head all the time
because your little dudes I still look
today he still goes by you know we had a
teammate I had a teammate of jason brow
and we call it like we call him
delicious I'm like you got to be some
type of sucker there's like he answer to
it to it we called it was it was
delicious and bit chips he answers to
both of them
I'm tell you pull up a picture friend
will you get a chance pull up a picture
Jason Brown man I will do it that's a
very common name there's gonna be a
million Jason no no no he would the
North Carolina no he would he play with
me on a Ravens Oh real call he's a
grown-ass man he's calling him delicious
he's so soft man
listen we played we played dinner one
time right so we play the Denver Broncos
yeah you know the altitudes crazy right
sure this do faked that injury door
two-minute drill to regain something you
couldn't breathe
how often does that happen fake the
injury hey bro we don't have time out
the hell are you doing what it cost a
time so we know we like Weezer bullied
office all the times when we're sitting
there and we're practice one day so like
Kelly Greg like just get sure pissed off
right so Kelly gripe you know realize
Kelly Greg was like a all-state wrestler
so like packed white defensive yeah we
call bunny like 6 1 no no no no 510 3 3
like 3:30
yeah he was everyone thought Tony
Siragusa was Kelly Greg was actually
that guy he was the mini-me he actually
played with GU so like he gets Jason
problem so we getting a big team fight
he's choking him and like he gets out
but relic like okay y'all on a fight
fight put us on the line so he already
got choked out rear naked choke doubt
punched in the stomach why are we on the
ground we have the red he stark Riley
guys I'm sorry can I say anything over
here funny
can I say this when he's Jason Brown
story yes okay so wait how long is this
guy a teammate of yours eight years then
we had the same agent he became the
highest paid center in the league when
he went to the ramps Wow so they're so
just like you guys just kicked his ass
for eight years I man first time like we
jumped Orlando Brown too like he came
back to Zeus yeah we jumped him he
laughed oh I like y'all [ __ ] so
so so all right so we everybody knows we
got a team chaplain right okay everybody
got a team chopper so we sit in there
and whatever we killed
Ralph whatever giving his message so
they I guess it's like confession time
or something right
so we sitting there and this dude walks
it no actually is no compressions like
he just made this [ __ ] up this is what
Jay says court like cornball man so
Kourtney's dude our mini mother so he
walks up to the fearless so he walk he
walks up to the front of the room he
says guys I got a confession we like
hope you all right he like my wife's
been out of town with we're like Oh bro
like we got you man it's okay we are
there's a couple of us in that row we've
in there he said I've been jacking off
for every day we say [ __ ] are you
serious
that's your confession you bit jerk at
all that's like an half-baked words like
you ever for weed we like we like bro
this man right here got a baby by a side
she going away you say you're confessing
about jerking off if you'll get your ass
out of here
we booted his ass off the stage like
Apollo and he was like upset too yeah he
was like thought like man if you don't
get the hell out of here where was he
from that he was this kind of a person
he's like a church guy like right now he
runs like one of the world's biggest
farms like core ball like you can't make
this up man if he saw you would he be
excited to see you all his first
reaction be like no everybody know like
I mean his hips his hips are even Bichir
enough
you know everyone thought we had these
the reunion shows that we came back and
he put on like another college dirty can
you tell when a player is playing if
they're gonna gain a lot of weight when
they retire or lose a lot of weight yeah
is it typically by position for the most
part yeah the little guy the little guy
was getting loose a ton of weight it's
FAU Jason Brown and Damon woody really
never would he lost a lot of weight see
buddy got too many kids how many kids
does he have more kids equals more
weight well Damon Damon
I think Damon uh we were neighbors too
he um he adopted - I think but I think
he has eight Phillip Rivers is gonna get
really big yeah it's listen it's too
many it's too many dumb juicy juice in
there it's too much of the sugars too
much stuff in there yeah any day of the
week you can go in there you can get go
you get real you can get go fresh fruit
snax go ger gogurt all that stuff got
cause Pluto still make snackable 'he's
Lunchables oh yeah lunch was yet now
they got it with the pizza and they got
it with chicken tenders ooh gross see
what you just open a month to eat you
just open a book about it when I was he
I would grow up with discs of meat and
why was I being fed that American cheese
- not even real cheddar cheese processed
yeah
50% of your cheese is real got the
ribbon flap in and red dye 88 so wide
receivers get bigger or smaller after
their career most of most of them get
big
Urbina gets fat shamed and they lose it
but a quarterback running back started
worse Oh running backs get fat exhale
yeah cuz their day if there's like
compact and they're short already yummy
and there lay there all legs and ass any
I mean have you seen jones-drew I wasn't
gonna that's my guy like a spear
his video of him at the rookie combine I
was like wow like it's all legs and he
round like a 4 3 you see ok well I'm
sure Jones would go here but he should
remember the story funny story about him
right so we're playing against a jet see
he talks match he talks he talks right
so like you know he I played against him
so many times so I kind of know how he
falls back so it's like one of these in
and a half runs nobody gives a [ __ ] you
know so I come back and I hit him right
and then it like so I hit him and I'm
kind of like on top of him and he like
getting up second I'm not getting up as
fast he won't so he comes to do this or
I get mad so I'm mushing but then what
happens is I I grab his arm so like he
got one hand or a ball but he got a free
arm that's what he try to push up so I
grab his wrist pin it down right so I
pinned it down right yeah his arm came
about this how his head
I said oh [ __ ] here [ __ ] whoa he got
so bad oh oh oh yeah got pretty bad like
oh [ __ ]
bro let me tell you something do you
want to see a guy get mad listen I play
like this
he's a that word so many times a kicked
off from our 30 that's how many flags
were throw this mister lacked up from
you you were 30 that's like 60 yards of
penalties it was like five personal
fouls because what happened is he got up
and did he threw the ball him so I swung
on him and then like his guys came to my
guy swung on but because I started you
could see in his eyes like fire at that
point you're like I've done what I need
to do so Jimmy a [ __ ] you got so mad
oh my god
all right last one six I have no idea
which one is are we just talking about
it's hot yeah it looks good though oh
yes lost New York
all right so gentleman just lost New
York my my breakdown here and the reason
I wrote that is I'm watching license
plate guy Instagram life who's friends
with a bunch of the players and I'm
watching him talked to other Giants fans
shout out to license plate guy I have no
idea who he is
yeah never met him but he's going this
is a tough time for us this is sad I'm
sorry Karen eight six five four this is
sad every fanbase loves their physical
safety it's the bit to me it's the
number one position that fan bases get
behind
he was the first pick of the second
round he was the underdog so he was the
all-pro like a multiple Pro Bowler he
was cool he were 21 I feel like when I
saw Giants fans Landon Collins was up
there in terms of other than Eli and
Odell and now the most popular guy on
the team and I also think when you start
looking at Gettleman and you realize
they don't move on from Eli that's 23
million they give Alec Ogletree 10
million a year third highest paid
linebacker in the NFL and I don't think
he's in the top twenty and a traded for
him to and they traded for him
struggling he struggled and coverage and
when you look at Gettleman 's past where
he let norman walk DeAngelo Williams he
went up and back with and Greg Olson he
was fighting with and Steve Smith hates
him if I'm in New Yorker I believe now
I'm going our offensive line still sucks
our defense is still a mess I think he's
lost New York well what happens right
what happens when you ever broke up with
your girlfriend usually you go back to
Owen right there just went off you send
a text or say hey how you doing she know
what time it is she's like oh he must
have broke up either so I feel like
tisha Mara like after they made that
mistake in side mcadoo and the whole Eli
debacle they wanted a safe place
somebody take you entrust somebody from
the circle of trust
they've always they've always promoted
from within you think about Reese you
think about some of the other guys
within the organization so gediman was a
safe space
gentleman's also from the old school and
gentleman's from the old school from the
standpoint is he doesn't really give the
veteran players to respect that they
deserve but also he's a guy that when
you look at his track record he's never
really paid a safety
he's never drafted a quarterback in his
career and now you're you're asking him
to have foresight or be able to be
innovative but he just can't at this
point he's 60s he's in a sleigh 60s he
is who he is so he's not gonna move on
you know so now what was the vibe of New
York today on your radio show of people
with the Landon Collins news what they
were hurt they were hurt because they
didn't understand
he's a homegrown talent and the fact
that you could have potentially got a
third round draft pick from Kansas City
last year if you weren't gonna bring him
back the guys on the forum you let him
walk without getting any compensation
maybe might get a football heard he that
he heard that a team was willing to
offer a first yeah I don't know about
that day that's funny like I said if
that's the case we need to go ahead and
get TMZ because they're the best
investigators it is out there forget
mother forget all that
it's TMZ to the bottom it is and if they
if it was the first on traffic out there
he needs to be fired ASAP hey Dad is
negligent yes and the fact listen he
talked he when he first got here talking
about being in quarterback Hill and I
don't understand how he's gonna say sell
to the fan base that this crop of
quarterbacks are better than the one
last year when he said he didn't see any
transcended talents last year so now
you're gonna say the ones here are
better when we knew that four of these
guys came in the league and they made
noise last year yeah they show splash so
now you're gonna tell us Oh kalimera
Haskins our better option than last year
right so I don't know how he's gonna
sell that narrative so where do you go
you're stuck in quarterback held it's
really funny that I've said this now for
two years that the Giants had an out and
it was when Ben McAdoo sattim and put in
G no no now whether or not he should
have put in Davis Webb regino I don't
really care my thing is the Giants
organization could have said at that
time Ben McAdoo made this we want to
move on from Eli anyway
yeah and forever we can put this on Ben
McAdoo we have to say it was Ben McAdoo
decision right and the organization went
on from there but they had an out and
because they went back to Eli they
showed that they they you know bow down
to the fan base but that's because they
didn't fly the kite right they they sort
of flew the kite and and said you know
testing it out there see how people feel
the fans Beggs overreacting but if you
start listening to the fans you're gonna
become one now what he did answer was it
friend says oh no it was for me because
I felt like Francesa came out and goes
who is this guy to me Tamir was Mara
right because you don't pull a move like
that without putting it through the you
know running up the chain of command
right and then the fact that he was like
okay well oh look what happened it
wasn't on the right way so then he fire
everybody I can say that it was him that
made the decision surprised nobody's
went off the record he said hey you know
he made the call my question right now
is Peyton took a pay cut his Super Bowl
year with the Broncos yes why is he lie
still getting 23 listen I've been saying
this all along
say hey we're gonna give you 12 get
gimmick giving them give him an
extension and then you can prorate it
overtime right oh that is a dummy
contract on him but that gives you some
financial relief if we were but he
doesn't need to make 23 million right
insane and then and then this is great
gym work right here because then the
second the third highest paid dueling on
your roster is Olivier Burnett 19
million dollars of cap it any can put
aside that that is less than that's
that's like less is seven sacks 19
million dollars how much did you pay for
your sacks you're paying two point
yeah about 2.5 million per sec I just
got an alert Adam Schefter saying
multiple teams calling about Josh Rosen
if you're the Giants do you try and get
Josh Rosen I mean that's a way that I
think's a face because at least we know
he looks like but then I don't know how
how you train for Josh Rosen and then he
played last year threw for over 2,200
yards and what 15 touchdowns or 22 tour
whatever it's hard to evaluate their
offensive line was a man offensive
coordinator was awful but what I'm
saying is if you do all that how do you
keep a lie around now that I understand
that Josh Rosen already got his money
ten million dollars you were paying up
front for him so now so now was one
know that I think his salary is like 1
million dollars two million dollars it's
like it really six total yeah a rest of
his cons right but for the rest of the
five years so but how can you keep a lie
there because now you stunting its
growth because now if you draft for Josh
Rosen now this is year two
now you only have three years so if he
we're gonna waste this year and they
have to evaluate him over the next two
ways no Dell and sake one yeah that's
what I'm tired exactly is is you know by
the time Odell's ready to like shine
we've already washed away he's like he's
not gonna be four three one four F
exactly he's not gonna be able to do
this stuff for F Ferraris are always in
a shot by the way so you better keep
take advantage of me while I still run
him good yes
all right so I went through as I said a
bunch of your Instagram too and I do
have some Instagram questions okay I saw
that you have a huge sneaker collection
yeah yeah and it made me realize you
have a very you know defined style what
do you think of the current NFL style
the supreme nation of like the wild
clothes and the holes in the shirt I'm
curious what you think about today's NFL
style
I think they too trendy you know I gotta
be you got to be able to figure out your
own style we had to get your own swag I
think they did you can't just turn on
and see what to change is wearing or
check out what what the me goals are
wearing I think NFL players have the
worst style of most of these oh they do
it's so so much that we well basketball
players are horrible too because they're
tall way with it though now they tall
and wearing some skinny jeans to Moose
knuckles nobody wants to see that
Tristan Thompson coming in looking like
like what's what's the the don't create
a fire bear oh yeah yeah he's coming
over the Hat smokey smoke smokey the
bear and LeBron a couple years ago with
the short suit no no not it yeah that
was horrible first of all I'm a grown
man I don't need you I'm not trying to
show it what did we new addition you
showing up to the finals with a gray
suit like a wedding suit yeah you doing
dead before that it was the season and
sweaters our worst dressed an NFL player
yeah absolutely because they look weird
I think that they're longer so that
things like work out for them better see
but damn well players I feel like
football players are the people at the
club they could wear great stuff by the
end of the night they're in a tank top
see but there see but see but basketball
players they're longer but you know has
to be specially made and you started
realized that certain things aren't
designed for your height mmm like I
don't want to see a plant pattern going
that high is like I'm having a seizure
looking at you yeah patterns moving I
don't want to see Russell Russell
Westbrook with his nipples out yeah like
if you're gonna wear that shirt rips on
it yeah I'm need you to put a pasty yeah
you know many children are watching I
don't want to we don't wanna see another
man's nipples alright so do you like
kneecap out I mean it works with his
haircut you don't like a kneecap you're
an tiny kitten listen where it works
with it see him what I don't like is he
like these dudes all shop at the same
spot by the time people figure out what
I'm wearing I go buy something else what
I got I don't know you tell me
Matt got us with lure pants next I
thought I'm supposed to go to a play hey
am i saying what I'm where I'm just
trying to figure out who won where Oh
where's Ely right nobody knows about
right so I pop up stuff like that then
Sol's a rapper figure out about it and
rap about it yeah everybody rush to it I
move on to something else
alright other thing I learned on your IG
those are cool let me see if we can get
a camera on this on Bart's foot that's
got a nice little brown leather with a
gray pattern well I know we got the look
we got to look Gucci joint I know we got
the Gucci going on and I really don't
wear things with with logos either yeah
cuz you're not supposed to I'm done with
logos because what happens is you
supposed to know if I have it on
something by the way you holding your
foot up here for this long is perfect Oh
probable another thing I saw on your IG
you raced a CrossFit guy and he popped
his handle there wasn't a CrossFit guy
rice always like pros vs. Joel's oh no
no so like I trained like I trained it
just facility I still training it's
called test and it they trained like
combine athletes like Flacco trained
they're like I got but then what happens
during a lockout we need to place your
train we trained there so I continue to
train there and they have this thing
where they bring bodybuilders in so then
we have like a competition
so so we're sitting there getting ready
to run new tire flips up like that bench
press stops I like that but then you do
40s so we're getting ready in the
athletes over there like warm it up get
ready to run their 40 because with the
bodybuilders we're doing stretching
curling what that's the meathead stuff
right so they send up their curling like
I have a few minutes yeah just get some
more bison but they're back to run so do
came and put it I've never seen anybody
pull a hamstring it's incredible like
running and then all of a sudden his
right leg goes completely straight
watches his body in the air what
happened after that
what did you do damage yeah you down for
the county bully pulled his hamstring
off the ball man off the bone he was
done so ambulance like Down Goes Frazier
what did it look like what does a
hamster the guy it just bleeds I mean
it's you know you it pulls the blood
pools at the back now I think you
probably took a protein shake
I don't know you're too old but I know
you a little bit hmm did you talk [ __ ]
right after it happened absolutely is he
on the ground right there yeah what are
you saying - as long as he ain't dead I
can spare Jay it's fair game what you
say Down Goes Frazier
sucks for you get up Craig get up quick
I've been down before
again dumb and then one other thing I
saw is you went to the Met Gala with Tim
Tebow James my date well it's his date
what well I was trying to make Tim feel
comfortable you know he's like his first
year in New York yeah yeah and I love
fashion - so who had the invite you were
Tebow Tebow had an invite okay I was hot
at that time I could have got it I could
have got this yeah you know uh so my
parents about that I was at the table
Rihanna Bruno was there what is the vibe
of being inside the Met Gala is
everybody letting loose because no
social media well I think that's after -
you know that's pretty much active today
after parties and stuff what happens in
the actual Met Gala I mean people just
walking around chopping it up you know
you said yeah that's so Brady there one
time - yeah Brady was there - I think my
question that I'll be worried about is
let's say I got the invite to the Met
Gala yeah super excited I'm gonna talk
to Reid I'm gonna talk to Brady but
they're also in their head going I want
to talk to Rihanna and I want to talk to
Brady so my concern was I would go up
and talk to someone they'd be like
listen man I got to
I don't know who the [ __ ] you are yeah
the bad part did you feel like a bum
right so you feel like a bum right that
happened no no no the part the part that
make you feel like ah man because you're
not in that world that's not your world
right I don't know you big that we're
going to ask you something it's cool I'm
good but will you go to the Met Gala
that's about like usually more about
entertainers and write and artists so
you walk the red carpet like we're the
photographers literally trying to figure
out who you were is that a new designer
for Versace no I'm not interested but
Tebow had to have not not many I mean
really many how was Tim Tebow on your
date Oh
Timmy's funny man he's a cornball
horrible hope he gets one off by is he
corny er than Jason Brown different type
of corny okay why he's a wildly and a
beef corny I don't know what that means
like I know Wally the be like aw shucks
dang it
like like I said personal know what's
the quitting but he is low he's more
horny than people think
really yeah he's more horny I figured is
there uh I mean I don't want to be the
first one and take that one no it's just
a lot of pent up stuff well he's engaged
now shouldn't shouldn't take long a few
other things I saw I asked you about
titty head you had a thing on your
Instagram about you through a flag back
into the crowd yeah cost you $25,000
yeah and I'm ever curious was there ever
a guy that got fined for something and
didn't realize that he was gonna have to
pay that amount of money and was like
completely thrown out like if if I got a
$25,000 fine for throwing one thing I
would be a mess the whole week see the
thing is you take it out before you see
it also people don't leave so you don't
even fill it because it's pretext see
but and the thing is like when I went to
my hearing it had never happened before
so no one ever thrown a flag yeah yeah
but first Matt my unicorn Wow so they
did know what's the penalty so I tried
to fight the ref so like they were
cheating like it was when the Patriots
went undefeated we were we were winning
and I was a year we had a bad season
because everybody got hurt but everybody
I came back for the game it's like week
15 and we're beating that we beat the
hell out of them
and on that drive they call for
fourth-down penalties on us and they had
to get a touchdown to win they call for
fourth down remember that wasn't when
they said Rex call the timeout we
stopped them all for from one they said
you remember that yeah it was on Monday
Night Football and they said sucks got
pushed backwards he touched Brady on
4:15 and touched him touched his helm
with the bad guys hand didn't even see
him Wow I think so
so all this is pent up in there and the
ref had been calling this boy and all
kind of crazy stuff all day he got
suspended too
he got suspended yeah cuz he argued he
got suspended yeah doing it so I just
got fed up so like I was like medicine
boy he's like and he's like have some
integrity I said I said he said
something I said have some integrity so
he's like I had enough you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
so he threw the flag and I'm saying [ __ ]
macho fly so I threw the flag in the
stands he threw the other one and at
that point I guess you're a pioneer yeah
I'm saying that you find out a few days
later you got $25,000 less than your
paycheck yeah yeah dad's building like
hey did you say anything about people I
was crazy and now if you look on it if
you if you ever look it up on it yeah
like I walked right by Bryant Bryant
look at me Brian scared of [ __ ] why do
you think the Ravens always seem to have
an edge over the Patriots they seemed
like the only franchise that can get it
done because they don't care like I
don't listen how does that permeate a
whole building where a whole building
doesn't care about the Patriots because
you know III don't know but I assume
that when the Patriots are playing any
team they feel like you my culture
figure this out it's easy to buy in a
game plan so from a defensive standpoint
I don't care if you've changed the
coordinator from Marvin Lewis to Mike
Nolan to Rex Ryan - Dean Peas - who I
could forget who they have now - right
now - Martindale now like you know
listen this is this is our identity this
is this franchise no matter how long is
the franchise is and I know ya know
during the Flacco era is like okay well
maybe no defense and it's a it's a book
that's in there to have all the da Vinci
codes
and we believe in those DaVinci codes
and we say you know what at the end of
the day you know that this game comes
down to physicality and we when I was
with the Ravens we always wanted to make
people have to make that decision is it
worth it and you know we just call it
the bird flu like so we would see
anybody and if anybody was questionable
doubtful with a dainty plan because Abel
there smoked and we had his other stat
after teams play us whether they beat us
or not what happened to the next week
they got destroyed cuz we damn near
killed him two years ago Jacksonville
was the same way I would bet on any bet
against any team that played
Jacksonville the week before because
they were just bashing yeah what was the
real feeling of that the defense towards
Flacco during that time well I was only
with Flacco for one year I should call
when Flacco firs got there because
remember Troy Smith was supposed to be
the starter he had me back up and sure
he got he lost 20 pounds Wow got sick
lost his job in the Flacco era started
black I didn't even know him start we
was on a plane Troy got sick and never
recovered and Flacco like started the
third preseason game and never stopped
there but you know it was funny because
I played with so many bad quarterbacks
you know I mean that it was like man
like so when he first got that call on
Freda so his nickname was Freedom fuchal
like I never cut no we never caught him
cross names freedom because he had this
uni but unibrow it's called my big
vertical oh no he's called him Burt -
yeah see yeah see now I got all this
money now he actually gets it shaved in
between a medal you got a full bridge
right there it was when he threw the
when he threw the first out route and
that thing has so much smoke on that
style so you know it's off like oh okay
we can work with this yeah because I
remember had played with Kyle Boller man
and listen I tell people all the time
and I know Kyle probably hates me before
because it's all love he was the
greatest opponent I've ever faced and
he's on your own team beat Brady be
Payton can defeat Kyle Boller
mmm Kyle Boller was just that damn bad
yeah well he could throw 50 yards from
his knees yeah I seen his dude throw
seven picks in a game seven Kyle Boller
or Nathan Peterman he may be the
inspiration
that Nathan Peterman looks - all right
so Flacco got there you guys were
impressed but as it was going on Flacco
has one of the most interesting careers
ever yeah because that run in the
playoffs was unparalleled I mean it was
it was Aaron Rodgers yeah it was Elias
right cuz Eli locked in he locked in and
he got into a groove and he didn't make
a mistake right and Flacco did the same
thing and he had a little luck now I
mean the the Cobi Jones yeah Robert
Kraft man you came out with the hot take
listen and the funny thing is like when
you say something and in the world
explodes you go I talk this [ __ ] every
day every day like listen I'm just this
is me being honest this I'm an equal
opportunist [ __ ] you called Jonathan
Stewart a snitch oh yeah well I'm just
messing around it's like sneha CIA stuff
no bike well my question for that was
the teams you've been on has every team
felt like there's one guy that that's
like in the owners part or the coaches
pocket and you have to say name no no we
all know those guys that's running up to
the running up to the owner how do you
find out that someone's been doing that
you want to put some false information
out there and see if it get cut and have
you done that before wait we just called
him the CIA we ever it was one it's one
in it is one on a jet right now and you
know he's knit dress snitching yeah how
do you so I I can't imagine being the
the snitch on the Ravens defense just
because of the what's gonna come your
way yes am I gonna die yeah like you
guys probably didn't have one no our
snitch
and I you can say snitch or you can say
the person that leaked stuff to like a
person in the media stuff like that yeah
I mean because they coaches and
sometimes players develop these
relationships with reporters people in
the media because when they play like
[ __ ] or the coach like [ __ ] they want to
have somebody they would have somebody
that could protect them yes with a story
oh it's not over therefore no you know
so on so you know and put that daily
information yeah I mean so yeah so what
I called Jonathan Stewart one it was no
reason in hell forget him and assign him
for that much because he wasn't a good
player no so now you sure love somebody
in there because you want to know what's
going on as I hate this guy isn't good
that's just the way it goes that's the
inside stuff that most people that play
understand so they see what I'm saying
but I wasn't I'm gonna see what I can
get out of here who do you think the
most popular snitches in the NFL right
now Ben Roethlisberger do you think so
a lot of people he'd say nothing right
now of course cricket only got a radio
so who is your favorite quarterback to
hit by Roethlisberger no I love Ben you
know me listen oh really I always say
this Ben is one of the few quarterbacks
dan come sit at the defensive table take
it you take it like a man
yeah I thought I killed him that 1ul on
Instagram I got him I called my Michael
Myers but remember Haloti Ngata broke
his nose like remember they were playing
and he came and he just put some stuff
in it man damn
so he'll fold up like a bad tent so I
can respect that well the one thing I
will say about Ben and I think he is a
Hall of Fame quarterback no doubt yeah
is young Ben when he was running around
Malibu's most wanted man with it with
the gochang he talked he got so many
sacks oh my gosh she's got those charges
bet he went straight corporate right he
cut the hair he did through the chain
away melody was like cheddar Bob yes she
can't he came in came in with the white
t-shirt had the big change you look like
a hip-hop dude did ya i swagged up man
now you got like got like locks right
now so he's like country look like duck
dynasty now what a commander 180 my I
kind of wanna wrap up with this as you
you were somebody that the media loved
talking to when you played and it was
one of those really like oh Bart's gonna
go in the media then you go right to CBS
and you're on like the main entity then
you're in New York on the main drive
time you know show what is your view of
the media now like what do you see about
this industry because you've seen so
many like avenues in it I think I have a
greater appreciation for the
storytellers and what the role of the
media is and how it promotes the game
how it sells the tickets how it pushes
you know advertising and things of that
sort but also confirmed to me what I
really always assumed a new
they have the people that talk about
sports on no [ __ ] and have to have the
people in industry just use cliffnotes
they just basically come in read the
read the headlines they don't really dig
in so if you really want to know more
about your teams I encourage people to
listen to your local reporters because
they're more entrenched in like
especially like the the mass because
I've been in both right because I'm in
the fan there's more local and then you
so you so it's more nuanced in it you
you go you have to dig deeper because
you have to give the the fans and the
listeners more on on the national
platform you just read you know you grab
a statistic you're doing fifty a second
yeah yeah and you're put your painting a
picture so you know but it confirmed cuz
man I can tell you how many times I've
just had a general conversation with
somebody off the air and they go steal
my [ __ ] and say it out they're like man
this dude is dumb as a box of rocks
Wow yeah really you're just gonna use
that my other question for you would be
you're talking about you know playing on
a team and if somebody said something
you're gonna handle it man if Mike
France has to talk [ __ ] about me I'd be
in his office the next day he's never
said anything about me never check the
record
oh he's come for people around you I
don't I don't listen the first thing I
had when we met each other first thing I
said likes I'm big on respect listen I'm
gonna respect you I don't know what's
going on yeah and that's what anybody
drama that you weren't a part of I don't
have to be here right you know I'm here
because I want to be here I'm just
having fun yeah I appreciate the
opportunity but one thing I won't
tolerate from anybody's disrespect
because if you disrespect me we have to
handle it right here and you have to
make the decision if it's worth it for
you right because no matter what if I
beat the [ __ ] out of you then I'll make
money off me beating the [ __ ] out of you
mmm don't matter
either way to help build my brand it
don't matter yeah it is my brand or my
backers yeah that's my shot you because
you did listen I'm not gonna come on
Brad I'm not gonna start it but i'ma
finish it right I don't take any
disrespect I'm gonna get you respect I'm
gonna come and speak to everybody I'm
have fun just watch what did you say to
him though off the top you said I'm
about respect yeah yeah yeah I mean
listen I don't give a [ __ ] I smack when
I asked what I might like so good to me
yeah I don't really give a sh you ever
sitting the seat a little bit longer
just so he knows no we indifference dude
okay but listen man let's see but this
is this is his life this is what yeah
I'm just I'm just right we're out having
fun having out what the hell I want to
do do you know what you want I'm just
doing [ __ ] yeah I mean I go did you
enjoy this yeah do very good 33% how
many I don't only see I was I don't want
to come in in and try and be too bright
so I only really get you 20% I got 13% I
kept my pass [ __ ] up you signed a
contract
yeah yeah I'm gonna talk to your lawyer
say okay I gave you twenty percent part
you're the man I appreciate it
why'd you do that
because it makes it an awkward moment I
like I'll get really self-conscious with
when that happen I like I like provide
an awkward moment this is the new jam
from rod Simba I know they probably came
everyone to freestyle right the way you
guys are awesome for Bart Scott I am the
lef koe man we will holler at y'all be
back on Monday
Bart seriously though appreciate you all
good hallo
peace guys
[Music]